Even if you don’t work for yourself, even
if you have a job inside a company and you
love it, that’s what you want to keep doing,
I would actually encourage everyone to think
about how they can develop multiple income
streams in their own life and in their own
business.
When I started my professional career I was
a journalist and I had been doing it for about
a year, and one day I got called into the
HR office and I got laid off without warning.
And they gave me a week’s severance pay.
Technically I had actually already worked
Monday so it was four days severance pay.
And I somehow had to figure out what to do
with myself.
And that, at age 22, was my first realization
that the things that we take for granted,
the things that we think are stable, are not
always.
If you take the initiative to develop multiple
income streams in your business, if you even
just spend a couple of hours a week developing
some kind of a side project for yourself,
there are a host of benefits.
First of all, heaven forbid something happens
with your day job, but if it does, you’ve
been cultivating something that, over time,
you’ve hopefully been able to create to
bring in additional revenue which creates
a cushion and gives you something else that
you might be able to pivot toward.
That’s great.
But let me make another case.
Even if you feel 100 percent sure that things
are good with your employer and are going
to stay that way, when you do entrepreneurial
experimentation on your own time you are making
yourself more valuable to your company.
In my book, 'Entrepreneurial You', I actually
tell the story of a guy named Lenny Achan.
Now Lenny was somebody that I got to know
because I was consulting for his employer.
At the time he used to work for Mount Sinai
Hospital in New York.
And I kept hearing about him.
People were sort of whispering about him because
he had risen so rapidly in the organization.
And so when I met him I was curious.
I said, "Lenny, what’s your story?
Tell me."
And it turns out he had started his career
as a nurse at the hospital, and by the time
I met him he was running communications for
the hospital.
That is not a traditional career path.
The vast majority of nurses are not doing
that.
But the way he was able to dramatically transform
his career and his income was that he had
become interested, on the side, on his own
time, with apps.
And so he learned what he need to learn in
order to create a couple of apps on the side.
His boss found out about it, called him into
the office one day.
Lenny was worried because he thought maybe
he had violated some policy he wasn’t aware
of.
But instead of firing him or punishing him
his boss said, Lenny, I hear you’ve made
some apps.
And Lenny said, well yes, it’s true.
I did.
And the boss said, we need someone to run
social media for the hospital.
I think it should be you.
And so he got that promotion and he did so
well with it, ultimately they gave him the
entire communications portfolio.
When you are learning and experimenting on
your own time, you are able to pursue your
interests, deepen your passions, gain more
skills and then bring all of that back to
work for your employer.
When they see that you’ve taken the initiative
to do that, it sets you apart.
The vast majority of people are not doing
that and it ultimately is likely to lead to
you being rewarded even more in your current
job and making you that much more secure.